the man sickened by the corona virus
entered the u.s. via Seattle
International Airport On January 15th
he's a resident of Snohomish Washington
north of Seattle
officials say he had traveled to the
region around Wuhan China where the
outbreak began the first case of novel
coronavirus is a Washington man in his
30s who returned from Wuhan subsequently
got ill sought medical care and was
promptly identified the man is being
treated and closely observed in a
Seattle area hospital he's described as
being in stable condition the corona
virus is believed to have originated at
an outdoor market in Wuhan that sold
fish and wild game it has sickened
people in China and other individuals in
Japan South Korea Taiwan and Thailand
several people are known to have died
from the virus it causes fever severe
respiratory distress and organ failure
chinese officials say it can be spread
from human to human travelers returning
from Wuhan should be on the lookout for
a fever and respiratory infection for
example a cough and difficulty breathing
if they have those kind of symptoms they
should call their health care provider
quickly last week officers at the
International Airport's in Los Angeles
New York and San Francisco began
screening travelers who began their
journeys in Wuhan the Seattle Airport
does not have extra screening the World
Health Organization will meet this week
to consider whether to declare the
outbreak an international health
emergency